soren to injustice too with our latest
character Black Canary this metahuman
has a definite canary cry but she also
loves to get her hands dirty and won't
back down from a good old fashioned
brawl Black Canary excels at close
quarters combat and employs numerous
techniques to overwhelm her opponent
keeping them guessing at every turn
don't mess with canary up close as a
judo expert Black Canary has many holds
and grabs including her combo new wings
incorporating a flurry of punches into a
judo hip tease her move hard lock will
punish those who are ducking with
another painful takedown with the knee
bash you were able to confuse your
opponent with a myriad of options
including going low delaying a follow-up
or even going for a combo starter her
special moves hi Perry and lo Perry will
instill fear into our opponents who
challenge her up close in addition her
hands-free maneuvers allow her to pass
through projectiles and leaves her with
several option finally she can use the
element of surprise with the canary drop
canary leaps unto her opponent to start
a combo which can be done up close far
away or even mid angry Canaries
character power is an ear-shattering
canary cry while the level 3 version may
take some time to build up its power is
unparalleled
finally this bird of prey pumps up the
volume with her super move sonic scream
look for Black Canary and a full roster
of DC heroes and villains and injustice
2 coming May 16th 2017